you want an awkward moment here it is
I'm not wearing any pants right now I'm
serious
[Music]
That awkward moment so that awkward
moment is a movie starring Zac Efron
Michael B Jordan and that dude I don't
know his name but I'll probably end up
knowing it soon that it was pretty funny
in this movie and the three guys were
pretty much the textbook case three guys
you're gonna have in a romantic comedy
seriously ones the ladies man he wants
to be single another guy is like the
friend but he's really funny and another
guy's going through divorce so you know
that sucks as for him don't worry man
math and statistics say it's completely
normal going to this movie I felt like I
was going to the dentist I was like yeah
let's get this over with right now if I
could be unconscious while it's
happening all the better not gonna lie I
enjoyed it I enjoyed it because I liked
the characters first of all the actors
in this movie did a good job pulling the
characters off and I liked the dialogue
in this movie the dialogue in this movie
was really witty and funny to an
unrealistic degree for sure but most
dialogue is the point is these guys
really bounced off each other really
well in a work for me in a real awkward
moment in this movie is that moment you
feel like you enjoyed this movie a lot
more than you probably should this
movie's a chick flick that's not made
for chicks it's made for dude so it's a
dude flick that's not like die hard as
everyone knows dude flicks are like die
are their action movies cuz what we do
to love but that's soft really mushy
side of us we like to bury deep down
inside underneath the John McClane isms
like to enjoy a good romantic comedy
that we can take a chick to and not feel
like we want to shoot ourselves in the
face I can say this movie textbook case
you see the characters you're like
alright I know your stories and I know
exactly how you're gonna end up in this
movie guess what in the end game that's
exactly where they end up you have Zac
Efron who meets this girl is funny witty
friend who has this really attractive
good friend who's a girl who's not his
girlfriend
they're just buddies though come on and
his other friend who was going through a
divorce where do you think these guys
are going to end up good job you're
absolutely right yep no twists and turns
no Fight Club ending another good dude
date movie he should watch on
Valentine's Day but if this movie is in
theaters long enough to make it to
Valentine's Day it's not the worst
Valentine's Day movie you can go and say
best Valentine's Day movie of course
will be Terminator 2 but if you don't
watch t2
here you go this movie what it really
reminded me of was American Pie if
American Pie was made for people in
their 30s in that I mean everything that
that could mean it's less juvenile
doesn't feel like you're in high school
it doesn't feel like it's a high school
movie it's like a date movie made for
adults I will say that awkward moment is
a good time no alcohol required which
was pretty awkward mom's walking out of
it I was like ah I didn't expect that
[ __ ] so that awkward moment have you
seen it what did you think about it or
if you want to be creative what is your
awkward moment and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more you
still don't believe in do you I'm dead
serious
nothing I [ __ ] you not man free balling
it for you did you know me I never lie